uh let me introduce dr khannan first uh
so that
uh
so that we can learn what he's going to
talk about so dr khanna is an
entrepreneur and a physician scientist
and now also a computational biologist
and we have been uh fortunate enough to
have several of these discussions with
dr kanaan and learned so much about
translational cancer research and its
application in india and i think it's a
great opportunity for the audience and
for everyone who is here today to learn
from his and his experience where his
focus of work was cancer genomics and
then utilizing different sequencing
platforms for immuno oncology for drug
discovery and development that led to
cancer immunotherapy and developing
those uh protocols for cancer
immunotherapy
and uh there are so many different
keywords that are associated with what
is going on with the uh with precision
oncology and all of that so
it's it's really we are very excited to
learn by by you dr shivikan
and anything anywhere anyone getting
ready for the future of genomics over to
you sir
yeah
thank you
can you guys see my screen
yes yes
okay thanks thanks mohit for the
wonderful introduction so basically
anything anyone anywhere is basically
from nanopores official website so you
can see here so let me go to the
beginning
i also have a presentation so i wanted
this to be a more interactive session i
don't want to bore the people
you know so if you are an ngs next
generation sequencing whether you are on
the matlab site or on the bioinformatics
side uh when people say ngs what do you
think about you always think about
illumina and ion torrent and other
shortly technologies but the world is
changing the world of genomics is
changing
at a very fast pace
so we started adopting nanopore
technology around 2017 2018 when the
technology was still at a very early
stage and a lot of people used to say oh
nana is not good it's only for research
it doesn't have the accuracy does not
meet the level of accuracy of illumina
but that's not true anymore so it's a
fast evolving and fast developing
technology
uh maybe i'll make the screen a little
bit bigger so that you guys can see yeah
so
i want to give some a taste of what's
what's coming in the near future so and
i'm not i'm not alone uh i am part of a
huge community of nanoproducers more
than 30 000 laboratories across the
world have adopted nanopore primarily
for studying microbiome uh bacteria
yeast fungi virus and
very recently during the covet pandemic
nanobook came as a very big uh solution
uh to for real-time genomic surveillance
of how the virus is mutating very fast
and spreading all over the
world and all the countries started
using uh so the adoption real adoption
of nanocore technology happened during
the pandemic so that's something uh
illumina would not have done that uh
because of it's a it's a capex heavy
equipment you you need to invest
millions of dollars to have an ngs
facility but nanopores like they have
different small small instruments for
big instruments so here they show uh let
me just scroll a little bit
so here you can see the range starting
from a flonal or smidgeon all the way to
the minions the gradient and then we
have the promethean so they have the the
complete range and nanopore is one
technology uh you don't you don't you're
not tied to the lab so you can literally
take it in wherever you go so people
have done it and even done sequencing in
a space in a space station and they're
done in remote corners of the world you
know so there's lot of information
available on the website
so
as a broad spectrum
what is the main use of this technology
uh just like any other ngs technology it
has a very
multiple use cases most common
how nanopart became very popular is
metagenomics especially when you have
they have this what's what's in my part
analysis i give you a tube i put colors
of environmental samples or some
bacterial samples or some i take a
sample from poultry form or i go to
himalayas and take a sample of the water
right so what's in my pot can you tell
me what's inside that tube that
colorless liquids that's the
metagenomics is the most important and
most popular use case and then of course
there's ugly genomics and then because
of the long reads uh you're able to have
uh n50 the context we have like we're
not limited by the lens whereas an
illumina there's always a size limit
it's like 143 and a base pass so here
there's no limit so you can have very
very long reads we have seen in our lab
minimum of 1.5 kb to 40 kb fragments
with very good overlaps so it becomes
very easy when you want to uh do a dino
sequencing and align and map the genome
and of course the most common use case
is the studying the bacteria the virus
and now recently a lot of work is being
done on human human genome that's what
we come in so we primarily focus on
cancer diagnostics and we do something
called the comprehensive genomic
profiling in our lab so we also look at
the tissue biopsy and we also do the
liquid biopsy so nanophone technology
has been used uh since the beginning in
our lab earlier we used to
do some comparisons with illumina data
and i entered data but now the accuracy
has improved a lot so we no longer do
this orthogonal validations we just go
direct with nanopore because we are
confident we are able to find the
mutations very easily
there are several unique advantages with
nana of course you can see there are so
many laundry technologies that is packed
by you and so many other guys like high
c bio nano almost every week we see a
new company pops up right so we have
singular genomics and so many new
companies coming into the space it's
very popular and then we have the mga
which is a clone of illumina but they do
it in a different way and they do have
some
unique advantages it's more affordable
compared to the aluminum uh but
generally entire ngs worlds separated
into short-range technologies and
long-range technologies among the wrong
laundry technologies packed by your
nanopores are the leaders unfortunately
pacquiao is too expensive so the per
sample cost is as is 300
sometimes if you 100 gb of coverage it's
more than three thousand dollars for a
small laboratory like us and most
developing countries uh this pricing is
not affordable unless you are a
university project you have some grant
money right uh so for clinical use it's
not making sense uh so we have been very
happy with manipur uh the per gb cost is
as low as 30 30 dollars so it's not
backwards 300 years 32 so it's literally
uh one is to 10 kind of ratio so i don't
think anybody can beat nanopore on on
the pricing side
the other major important advantage in
nanopore is uh it's a real real time
sequence so in illumina it's like a one
week long pipeline both the wet lab and
bioinformatics three days for the
wetland minimum and another two three
days for the bioinformatics so if i get
a sample on a monday i can give a report
on a friday or saturday sometimes you
know some holidays comes or something
happens some delays happen sometimes it
may take longer than a week
seven to ten days that's why most ngs
laboratories and genomic service protest
they don't give a turnaround time less
than three weeks they give typically
three to four weeks but in nanopore i
can do it the same day i start from the
morning do the dna army isolation do the
library trip in the afternoon by evening
i can load the sample so this is this
picture you can see the the minion
device which is a most affordable device
anybody interested in genomics they can
start buying this the instrument comes
free of cost you're basically paying for
the flows of the agents uh the startup
cost is only like five thousand dollars
it's very very very very low low economy
uh anybody can start building secrets
anything anywhere and anyone you don't
have to be a ngs expert and uh it's kind
of you know the kids comes with
excellent protocols uh both on the vet
lab side also on the biometric side they
do provide a software online cloud-based
software for the data analysis
especially if you're doing meta genomics
projects it's one of the easiest to
start start with the rapid barcoding
game and you can start playing
metagenomics in the lab every day it's
very easy to auto so we have made it a
mission
uh to help everybody to adopt nanoporter
now this is free of cost right so if you
are interested call me i will help you
set up the lab i'll help you with
onboarding you know so we we have a team
of people who can support you so we
don't want anything in return we just we
just want people to start using nanopart
technology target illumina those are the
dinosaurs of the past right let's move
on to the future that's why i said
getting ready for the future of genomics
the way we see it the next 10 years
long-range technologies are here to stay
and more and more competition comes and
the price is going to come down and it
could be as low as 9 000 per gb
so in ngs you always go with the per gb
cost right so that's it's making a lot
of economical sense especially for
emerging markets like india africa south
america asia pacific
everywhere you know you can do it and uh
again the time taken is just 24 hour to
48 hours uh maximum you can do you can
completely max out the floor in 72 hours
so that's a huge advantage example that
in real time as soon as the data is
being captured it's up to the server and
you can continuously monitor the data
within six hours for example kobe virus
uh we can do it in within six hours we
can actually tell you what variant
they have a very nice protocol of course
you'll have data in the first 30 minutes
itself but we wait for four to six hours
to get some confidence on the very
visited delta variant or micron even if
it's an omega not a sub variant so we
can do all that so we have an abl lab we
do covet testing also and we also do
that for our search purposes under icmr
guidelines we also look for variants
because we have a mrna vaccine project
where we use nanopore extensively so
without nanakula i don't know can we
even do this kind of work you know so
kind of the time the time turnaround
time or the time it takes to develop the
data
so it's a very simple uh prepare your
samples then sequence and analyze three
step process
and let me quickly walk you through uh
the three main products so you can see
minion uh it's starting from thousand
dollars you know so it's a starter packs
actually five thousand dollars when you
add the kids and the agents and you can
see grid ions starting from 50k and
promethean they have two two kind of
offers it's actually two pk instrument
but you can go for the p2 which is more
affordable so if you are a university
lab or a commercial lab and you want
best of both worlds there's a difference
between the mania and flow cells and the
promethean phosphorus so i would
recommend go with the gradient gradient
gives you five new cells
and the p2 so you have two prometheans
so you will have the flexibility of
using both meningeal cells under
promethane process depending on what
type of data your customer wants right
so and here you can see in the product
specifications what can we do with
nanopore everything you can do in
illumina you can do with nanopore
it's not like you know only illumina is
good at snps and genotyping we can do
snp detection dynamo in fact it's a lot
better
homopolymer detection is also very high
and recently people have done
benchmarking studies like nature
publications many publications
illumina vs nanopore versus pack bio
they have done the negative neck
comparisons with known samples and
nanopore has come out as a clear winner
uh there's a there's a page i want to
open that there's a page that talks
about the accuracy and base level
accuracy and also at the genome level
and the chromosome level accuracies and
nanopur always comes at a huge winner
and at a very affordable price so this
is like
like a superior technology at a more
affordable cost another big advantage in
nanopro is the methylation so no other
technology gives you the advantage
of both genetics and epigenetics on the
same run or the same experiment imagine
if i have to do illumina
ngs i have to for example illuminates a
company called grail they have done
liquid biopsy for multi-cancer early
detection
they have to do they have to split the
dna sample into two vials one wire goes
for normal uh variant calling pipeline
dna mutations another while goes for the
epigenetics the bisulfide sequencing so
they have to split it now
what is the ratio the proportions did it
is pretty exactly equally complicated so
the sampling bias comes in the picture
but in nanoproduction are spitting the
entire sample run is run through the
same native barcoding protocol and you
get uh this raw data the raw data can be
analyzed in two different pipelines so
splitting happens at the bioinformatics
level not at the wetland level so so
there is no sampling bios the same
sample you get base modification
especially the methylation so that is
the
one of the main reasons many people are
now switching over from aluminum from
bisulfate sequencing switching out to
nanopore is because of the metallation
protection another huge advantage
especially for cancer research we not
only look for small mutations we look
for big mutations the anything more than
50 base pair called the structural
variance sv detection and also have to
take facing so this is something not
many people know this
people report egfr mutations for example
the cis and trans so depends on let's
say i have two types of mutations uh the
la-58 are sensitivity crossing mutation
or t-summon dm which is a resistance
crossing mutation if these two mutations
come on the same strand of the dna then
the resistance biomarker overtakes the
sensitivity biomarker but if they come
on the opposite strands then the patient
is still sensitive to tk so this has
some direct implications in tyrosine
kinase inhibitors
so we call this company diagnostics like
drugs like airlocation name j fitness
and all these pkis tyrosine kinase
inhibitors which target the egfr keras
of b ref very important to know that
system trans how can we do that you have
to do hypertech facing you have to know
if my cluster of mutations are they
coming on the same strand of dna or they
coming at the opposite strands of dna so
hypertype facing is coming up in a big
way in cancer research and another hot
area is the transplantation medicine so
where you have to do excellent typing if
you're going for bone marrow
transplantation so cancer patients
leukemia lymphoma so many patients they
go for bmd also hematopoietic stem cell
transplantation so
typically they go with the relatives
some matched donors sometimes today
donors are very difficult to get you
don't have siblings you don't have any
family members to give you bone marrow
then you go for matched unrelated donors
mud in a mud case which is more common
nowadays what we do is something called
haploid identical that means a hundred
percent is not a match but fifty percent
match but the fifty percent match is on
the same strand of dna so half low
identical uh so recently there was a
nature publication where they showed
are 21 doppelgangers for every every
person walking on this planet earth 21
people in this planet who are exactly
like you
they also look like you they also have a
similar genome you know the facial
features and everything so it's very
interesting people so finding an
undulated unmatched donor at the haploid
identical is becoming more and more
easier nowadays so this is truly
revolutionized uh transplantation
medicine that's where hla typing
on anterior actually alleles the msc
class one glass to loci very easy to do
on the nanopart platform and again in
agri genomics and plant genomics
wherever you're working on new species
you don't have a reference genome and
now we have a pan and human genome pan
genome project and we also have the r.1
and so many other projects so assembly
is dino assembly right so this is the
the key so highly recommend uh go to the
nanopore website nanoprotect.com and
click on the resource center
on the resources so here you will find
all the latest uh videos and stuff and
uh let me quickly walk you through the
community so anybody can have a free
account and here you can see i'm logged
in i'm in the dashboard and you can see
there's a huge community active
discussions are going on also you have
all the new releases software downloads
and you can check the protocols you know
it's very easy to getting started with
nanopore now you can you have all the
protocols here and for different
different kits it's very easy
it's a lot more simpler than illumina if
you're coming from illumina it will be a
delightful experience uh working with
nanopro and they have different products
for example extraction protocols are you
starting from dna or starting from rna
what is your material like they make it
very easy you know there's also a
protocol builder which can basically
walk you through the different sample
types
and what type of validations you want to
do so you can see tissue cell culture
fluids whole organism agarose blood
environmentally fmp is true you're not
limit there's no limit any sample type
and then depending on the organism so
they have different protocols they want
one for mammalian one for plant elected
so pick the protocol that you need and
follow that to the line don't change
anything it is guaranteed to work you
know not much i can i can tell you i'll
just quickly show you this video
[Music]
so uh let me go a little bit back so
here so this is the flow cell
okay so
you see this small area here uh this is
where we drop the sample so it's very
simple and uh and we just there's a
small we have to open that spot on that
lid and then put drop drop drop other
than it goes inside so it's basically
like electrophotic chamber so there is a
upper chamber and lower chamber and then
there's a asic chip on is the
nanoprocessing embedded it's basically a
protein nanoprobe and once the dna goes
inside it's basically threaded threading
through the nanoprobe so then the asics
are reading the critical signals which
the software will interpret that's why
the base quality comes so this is where
real-time baseballing can happen so you
can monitor the data in real time and
once you exhaust the dna in the top you
can basically stop it
and this is as part of the library this
is what you're doing so this is your dna
sample and what you're doing is
basically you're attaching this motor
protein on the adapter sequence
and here you can see these are these are
the a6 chambers this round things are
the membranes on which the nanopores
impedance so there's a 2040 membrane
wells each containing at least one
sometimes it may contain more than one
uh but typically now the the
optimization has happened a lot you only
find one nanopore per uh sometimes the
nanopore is not fully fully formed maybe
it's broken you do find a few channels
but then you receive a few channels the
protein has denatured or it is folded
it's not working uh but majority of them
70 80 percent is still work so even
though you're guaranteed 2048 force by
then you receive it during the shipping
and logistics you may not get 2048 so
they say
minimum 1500 or 1700 is covered under
guarantee if it is lower than that then
they will replace the leave of brand new
floor you know so
so nobody gets hundred percent capacity
that's something that you need to
consider
[Music]
okay so this is important steps you can
see this tether is going to catch this
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so this is how it works so
basically when the dna is being threaded
there is a disruption in the ionic
current which is detected uh earlier i
used to think it is threading one base
at a time but that's not correct it's
actually trading four to five bases at a
time and different posts have different
uh speed limits and depending on the
speed the faster it goes the lesser the
accuracy the slower it goes the higher
the accuracy so it all depends on you
want a
structural variance a bigger i don't i'm
not caring about snps or single
nucleotides i only look at large things
then you can go faster but if you're
doing varying detection you're looking
at a single nucleotide based level in
things then you have to go slower
okay so i think you've got the picture
so let me open
uh
the presentation
i'll just quickly show you
so
why we call it as the the future
of genomics right uh so
illumina has been there for a long time
illumina and other guys iron torrent
they haven't done much innovations
this it's the same technology they had
20 years ago they still keep selling the
same things again and again but nanopart
comes up with a lot of new information
almost every year so they have this huge
conference called london calling every
year so this is these slides are taken
from the
plenary lectures uh from the london
calling 2022 i just picked some
important slides in that
uh so the first is you know you look you
can look at the evolution of the
technology from 20 2017 2018 so they had
the millions the gradients and then then
they launched the flonals because some
people said banana is too expensive
for a smaller liabilities then they came
up with the smaller ones which only has
126 channels the mineon has 512 times 4
so you have 2048. and the promethean has
three thousand so promethean has a
bigger capacity if you are doing uh
plant genomics project the inner
sequencing you are depending on the size
of your uh
samples uh how big the genome is how
much coverage if you want 100 gb to 300
gb kind of coverage then you have to go
with the property
and again the accuracy has improved a
lot since 2017 2018 now in 2022 uh we
are already at a very advanced level
that
every technology has its own uh you know
product development life cycle and it's
already at a very very advanced stage
i'm not sure how much more new things
they can introduce they already
introduced so much new things uh this is
at the pinnacle of you know it's uh it's
everything that we have hoped for
and earlier it was called r 9.4 now it's
10.4 the r10 series has clearly clearly
have a huge huge performance update how
because mainly you can see in this graph
so you have this different the bases per
second bps uh you know so used to be 520
then 400 and 216 so the slower it goes
uh the more accuracy the software is
able to regain my so basically it is
artificial intelligence uh running
behind the scenes so we used to have
algebra at the beginning then we have
guppy so they guppy their different
versions uh so always use this always
check the version we install the latest
copy when you analyze the data and we
highly recommend the minion mk1c which
comes with the screen it has an onboard
gpu and one terabyte storage uh the
regular minions they have a temperature
problem if you keep it in a normal room
i had this uh problem uh we we have like
five six millions lying around in the
lab
so there's too much heat uh creates a
problem especially in india
so i recommend go with the minion mk1c
uh which is same similar costing no big
difference plus you have the advantage
of a very good thermostat it controls
the temperature very well uh the minions
the standalone minions don't have that
option
uh then if you want if you have the
budget go for a grid right so that's
something
and now the the good news is it's
backwards compatible so if you have the
older online process well accuracy is
not an issue for your data you can still
work with that and they're also forwards
compatible so you can basically use any
kind of floor cells
on the different ways to run on the
prometheans you can run
single samples you can run you don't
have to if you have p24 or p48 no need
to put all 24 at the same time you can
just run a two or three chromium
fluorescence at a time you have a lot of
flexibility uh especially if you're
doing human genome we recommend minimum
like two or three maybe up to five five
is a lot
but two to three is fine people have
done very promising you know like for
here you can see mad loss has more than
170 gb
uh as data has been generated from the
new kit 14 uh which is currently running
at 400 bps right so so the new kit 14
chemistry the kit 12 came then the kit
14 has come
so it's early access so the existing
current users can get access to this
people who are interested in in the
accuracy
and they've done a lot of improvements
on the motor and the motor adapters and
also the chemistry that's what's
happening in the kit 14 so this is
currently now available many also
initially they launched they'll say it
is early access but after wait for a
couple of months it will be available in
the regular store so i highly recommend
if you're looking for accuracy go for
k40 if you're looking at structural
variants under log large proposable kind
of things or metagenomics but you don't
need kit 14 you can go with the kit
voila the older kids are not a problem
the more interesting part here is uh if
you have the greater iron or permit and
the bigger instruments now i have a like
like a tuning i can i can increase the
speed i can decrease the speed how fast
the dna is being threaded this is not
possible in any other technology you
only see this in nanopore and i can
literally control uh the accuracy the
sit here they have shown the data for
simplex accuracy and the duplex accuracy
so it's a tunable run settings notice
never this is like you know like like a
science fiction like a dream come true
you know
depending on the kind of uh and then
that's i i forgot to keep on slide
there's another another very interesting
feature in nanopore called adaptive
sampling today if you do like illumina
you know you everything is amplicons you
need to design primers you have to make
the pcr
products you have to amplify certain
regions of the dna right and then you
have to sequence it
but adaptive sequencing is like no need
for sampling applicants nothing in the
software we program these are the
regions let's say i'm working on
chromosome 8. chromosome 8 is my
interest i'll give the reference genome
for chromosome 8 as one of the uproar
file formats uh so i'm doing a whole
genome project i'm literally putting an
entire whole genome of the human dna in
the sample
but the when the dna is being threaded
the software will identify okay this
does not belong to chromosome 8 it will
reject it it will spit it out it's
called a you know adaptive sampling and
when the dna the next strand goes inside
it says oh this looks like chromosomal
i'm going to continue sequencing so i
don't need applicants however you need
applicants
just go with adaptive sampling the only
challenge there is you will not get
hundreds of gbs of data because are you
are getting rid of 90 of the unwanted
dna you are focusing on the
highly focused dna but then
you are looking at the dna in the native
conformation with the base modifications
you are not changing it same same with
rna another huge plus point in nanopore
is the direct rna sequence so there's so
many features in nanopore once you start
uh learning about that they say man why
are we still doing illumina
or any of the shattering technologies
once you go into nanopore world you
never come back
you know so again uh for a long time
nanopart used to be just a single reach
so now they're introducing the duplex
feature the kits are not yet available
it's coming soon
so this is how the duplex lead works
so basically what it does it's it's
stretch one one half of the dna first
but then there's a connector link and
then it goes to the other end same like
how lubino works but they have done some
modifications in that to avoid the ib
infringement with the illumina
and now we have this uh three major uh
pose so we have three major flow cells
so we have the armenian series we have
the r10 series and then the new new rx
series the r11 dual length and something
will come with that in the new series
currently the r names and arctics are
available 9.4.1 and 10.4.1
we have completely started using 9
series we are now using the 10.4.1
this is giving very good accuracy for us
and we are able to get
you know like a complete whole genome
coverage uh at a 3x to 30x and adaptive
sampling of those 500 genes something
like foundation medicine or garden
health the comprehensive genomics there
are 500 genes which are important in in
cancer so we are doing adaptive sampling
for those five regions we focus on that
and this is some some data represented
about form of polymer accuracy it's very
nice
and also you know like the raw red
accuracy theoretical maximum output in
72 hours how much you can generate you
know
and then where are where are we now so
we are now with ramora so ramora is the
latest for the methylation and here are
some some examples you can see the
precision and accuracy uh it's already
it's giving the best bang for your buck
compared to my sulfate sequencing so if
you are into methylation uh nanopore is
the best option for you right now you
know you could do both genomics and
division of excellent english
last
yes so we'll take questions now
thank you dr shebi for this wonderful
uh overview and understanding of the
nano pro technology
and uh there is also there was also a
comparison so uh for for our users and
viewers uh i think uh
many of our users and viewers have been
uh students and faculty and for students
i think um
one of the things that have been a
gap or perhaps many of the
biotechnologists and biochemistry
students
would want to know much about
how the data is generated so i'm just
summarizing that this has been really
helpful for those who would want to know
how the data is generated and what is
the industry standards because many
times especially with faculties who are
also working and want to conduct
experiments are kind of outsourcing this
to the industry this sequencing work to
the industry and uh then they're getting
reports and then they are
learning about uh what is the possible
insights that they can gain from the
data however like uh having an in-depth
understanding from this session is going
to be very much helpful in designing the
experiments and even like before
designing uh hypothesizing the
experiments so thank you so much dr
khannan for this uh insightful talk and
uh we started from clinical informatics
by dr jeet sarkar and then we learned
about how the data is being generated
and then uh what we want to uh know also
there are some questions so let me read
that out to you uh so keeping uh so one
question that i'll read now is keeping
some of the limitations of nanopore
technology in mind in your perspective
what are some of the ways the technology
can be further improved in the future so
where do you see that uh the future with
nanopore technology how they can evolve
further from this yes
yes so like i said the base calling
algorithm can keep on improving so one
of the huge advantages in nanopore is
uh we have done some some sequencing way
back in 2018 that raw data are still
lying around
every time they release a new version of
guppy on it on the new version of all
the software medical remo on everything
i can go back and re-analyze the raw
data i get i can retrieve more
information so that's the that's the
beauty of nanopro
because the base calling algorithm is
improving its runs on artificial
intelligence behind the scenes the more
trading data set you use to train this
algorithm the better it becomes right it
also opens up the possibility let's say
you are working on a very unique kind of
project which nobody has done everybody
is working on model organisms let's say
you are organism let's say you are a
diabetes professional working on gila
monster we don't have a reference you
know pervilla monster or the commodore
dragon for example right but the saliva
has the
diabetes treatment so you're working on
that you don't have a reference team so
you're completely doing something from
out of the scratch i take monkey box for
example right and nobody has built a
monkey box reference team and you are
the first guy doing it so then you can
basically train your own
algorithm so the software gives you that
the ability uh to train based on your
own training data sets you have like
gigabytes of data lying around in your
in your software database in your hard
disk you can train it and you can
customize it especially on the i highly
recommend there's one talk from one of
the nanopore team members uh they talk
about uh how to customize uh albacore or
guppy or remora for your your particular
lab scenario and i also highly recommend
ap to me labs uh this is a tutorial
website so they have plenty of uh
tutorials
and uh you can see uh they have
different different uh versions also
released and they have fun
share this on in the chat so there was a
question next question was
like a full guide or these tutorials i
think this is the question yeah so all
students go to labs.aptoma.io
and you have plenty of tutorials you
know let me let me click on one of them
and uh you can see the first start of
the installation right so you need to
install docker
to access the server so you can just
install it on your desktop and then
start with the basic stuff like
introduction to fastq the vcf file if
you're interested in variant calling the
bam file phosphate do the basic qc
tutorial start with this and then here
you have a adaptive sampling and if you
are into plunge in the next do the
assembly highly recommend you do the
metagenomics the epitome sequencing uh
16s analysis uh also they have other
other examples also for example if you
are in covid biology highly recommend
the sorcery do analysis
uh so let me just open it quickly i'll
show you
so basically if you're familiar with
jupiter notebooks uh so this is how it
looks so right now it's a static uh page
but once you connect docker and you have
the epitome labs up and running uh i can
click on any of this code chunks and hit
enter the code will run so now it's just
a static html page so here we'll have
like uh instructions followed by chunk
of code so it's very easy to follow
these tutorials especially if you're new
to working in a command line
so jupyter notebooks if you are if you
are into bioinformatics you need to know
jupiter notebooks
that's something i recommend everybody
get familiar with working with jupiter
thank you thank you so much dr khannan
and i'm just looking at the website i'll
share it with our audience and
i think we are out of running out of
time and thank you so much for your
participation in this keynote session